I went through a first year in office as
governor where you come in with
tremendous expectations and you try very
hard to define a reform agenda and a
year later you wake up and you say wait
a minute not everything has worked it's
difficult the effort to reform any
system any structure is fraught with the
risk that the forces of the status quo
will array against you whether it is
hospitals weather is the unions that
work in the hospitals whether it is the
teaching establishment so and it doesn't
mean they're bad good and different
during videos it just means that those
who are benefiting from the current
system don't want things to change the
president has encountered that has he
pushed aggressively enough for reform in
every instance no I don't think so in
financial services I've been critical of
where he has ended up until very
recently with Paul Volcker's ascension
on the issues of restructuring the banks
which i think is important on other
issues I think he has been spectacular I
think his the tone that he accept that
the fact of a president who is
thoughtful who is smart who's
inquisitive who tries to address issues
whether it be global warming or our
relations with foreign nations at a
level of intellectual accuracy and
thoughtfulness is wonderful to see but
these issues are sometimes intractable
they look at the roadblocks to progress
in the Middle East he's tried he has
appointed superb people doesn't mean
that you can get parties that have
irreconcilable differences to sit down
into great so I think he is a wonderful
public servant he will go down I'm
persuaded as a great president the
recent political bumps with the election
of a Republican senator from
Massachusetts are part of the both
maturation process and process of
learning how to use the levers of power
that will make them stronger in the
years ahead
well look I hesitate to say I'm giving
advice I just do but but he hears what
I've said in what I've written for Slade
and for and elsewhere there is a choice
that the White House has to make at this
point do they go the path of incremental
ISM do they choose to try to be
incremental in their efforts and the end
there by reach accommodations with a
Republican Party in a spirit of
bipartisanship or alternatively do they
do what I would encourage which is to
say wait a minute we have a progressive
agenda that agenda of reform and
financial services and health care and
education is correct we still have 59
votes in the United States Senate we
still have a very significant majority
in the House of Representatives we will
do everything we can to enact a
meaningful fundamental reform agenda
because that's what this nation needs
let's not kid ourselves we are at a very
treacherous point in terms of our
economy in terms of our competitive
position visa via the world in terms of
the social contract that that has been
crumbling in our nation and so if we
don't take those fundamental steps will
be in trouble so I would encourage them
to be aggressive do that which is
perhaps riskier which is to push the
progressive agenda at this very moment
and if it leads in November consequently
to a choice to be made by the Elector
that's good let the public see a choice
between a democratic party that believes
in progressive values in a Republican
Party that's standing in opposition and
we will see which way we go I think the
mistake they have made and this has been
a mistake of tone and a mistake of
communication has been to let the
Republican Party over the last number of
months appear to be the party of
populist anger and it is absolutely
mind-boggling that sarah palin and scott
brown have been the beneficiaries of
populist anger rather than barack obama
and democratic senators so i think that
is a communication problem that we need
to think about and overcome
you